so next up we have pradeep ravi kumar
talking about learning mini max
estimators via online learning take it
away
um let me unmute myself um
so thanks to the organizers for inviting
me to speak at this workshop
and
thanks to all of you for
attending this talk as well so what i
want to talk about today is
what
one should really call learning to learn
so let's see um of course learning to
learn is kind of an overloaded term so
let's see what i mean by that
specifically
so the basic setup is
common uh to just standard statistical
machine learning
so i'm given n id samples x1 through xn
drawn from some statistical model um p
theta star with parameters theta star
that
are really
lying in some domain
um capital theta okay so my overall
family of statistical models is given
here and the goal in statistical machine
learning is to infer the underlying
statistical moral p theta star
or just imagine its theta star if uh the
model is identifiable from just the
samples x one through x a
so that's the learning problem um and
under various assumptions of the family
of statistical models and the domain and
the type of samples you have different
estimators different algorithms
different analyses and so on
so
let's
now zoom in a little bit into
estimators
or learning algorithms if you will so
i'm going to do that but theta hat they
take as input
a set of samples
um so here script x is really the domain
of an individual sample so you're given
a set of samples and the goal of the
estimator given the set of samples is to
output a parameter right
now the question then is
um so this goes against the foundations
of
statistical machine learning how do i
then talk about what a good estimator is
um again the first few slides are
essentially just going to be
just setting up the notation of
something that is very standard um so
how do we then talk about
a good estimator the way we talk about a
good estimator is through
uh the lens of a loss function
that um in this context imagine takes as
input two uh potential parameters and
tells us how far apart they are okay so
essentially if the true parameter or
model is theta star and i output theta
hat of x one
through x n right so this is again the
output of my estimator this tells me the
loss that i would incur
now because the set of samples is random
the estimator
or the output essentially of my learning
algorithm itself is random and so would
be the loss so you could be extremely
unlucky or extremely lucky so it's
typically much more natural to talk
about the risk instead
and
what we mean by risk in machine learning
is really the expected loss
so here what am i taking the expectation
over the samples the n samples that i'm
drawing from the underlying statistical
model so here the two arguments are the
true
statistical model theta star and this is
now a learning algorithm or an estimator
okay
so given this notion of risk function i
can then ask hey give me a learning
algorithm that attains the minimum
possible risk
but the problem with this question is
that there's a very trivial answer to
that which is that
i think of this constant estimator that
no matter what samples i see i'm always
going to put theta star
now you can see that this would have
essentially zero
risk
for most reasonable loss functions and
that makes it um you know
kind of
um
a very trivial answer to what is a very
complex question it's a way to get
around this right but this is clearly a
bad answer if my model was slightly
different right so if a model wasn't
beta star but maybe theta star prime
right then this would give me a very
very wrong answer right so how do we
talk about that we really need a global
notion of optimality where i allow for
multiple possible uh statistical models
that could be true and so one very
natural notion is worst case optimality
or minimax optimality which you can
think of as
saying um that i'm going to allow nature
so no matter what learning algorithm you
pick okay so this is theta hat which is
my estimator you're going to allow
nature to
pick the worst case statistical model
okay so once i fix data hack this gives
me the worst case risk that my learning
algorithm would satisfy
would incur and then my goal
is to find the learning algorithm that
would suffer the least worst case risk
okay so this is
minimax optimality and obviously this is
a very very well studied notion in
statistics and statistical machine
learning
but how do we
obtain minimax statistical estimators
the typical way it is done is really
problem specific approaches where i
think about what are the class of
statistical models i'm working with what
is a loss function what is the domain
right and all these different
facets and then i hand construct
minimax estimators that i would then
argue through postdoc means that it um
is at least approximately going to solve
um this optimization problem
but in general we don't even explicitly
grapple with this mini max optimality to
begin with we typically have some other
estimation principles like likelihood
principles maybe i have a bayesian
estimator with some reasonable prior
maybe non-informative prior what not and
i come up with the estimated theta hat
and then i want a reason that hey it is
actually minimax optimal um if not
exactly in the sense that it exactly
solves this uh min max problem at least
it's asymptotically meaning the limit as
the number of samples n go to infinity
um maybe allowing for some constant
factors and so on
and we typically
do that using various information
theoretic tools
again it's an information theory
question because we really don't see
theta star we only see
a lossy
facet of it which which are the n
samples
so
this is
the state of effects um and
the question that we wanted to ask was
is it actually possible to
algorithmically derive in other words
learn
how to learn meaning that learn how to
estimate by solving this min max problem
it is after all a min max
reasonably well defined min max problem
right so
um why not just solve
right
so
essentially if i look at this one
you know the midnight's problem one way
to look at it is as a zero-sum
statistical gain
between and this is how in fact um if
you look at open up any decision theory
textbook this is how it is motivated as
really a statistical gain between a
learner
whose
action space is the set of possible
estimators okay so if i'm the learner i
would my action would be to come up with
an estimated theta hat
and it's a game between this learner and
nature which you can think of as the
adversary which can pick
any statistical model it can it can so
desires from the given family of
statistical models
okay so it's really this min max game
between these two players
and the question then is can we solve
this zero sum statistical game
algorithmically
no matter what the loss function is no
matter the domain is um
of either the samples or the parameters
now stepping back a little bit uh and
just thinking about this min max
zero sum game or zero sum game
um
if this risk function is actually convex
concave remember that i'm minimizing
with respect to the estimators and
maximizing with the speed of the um
the model true model parameters so i
really wanted this function this by
variable function to
be convex in the first argument and
concave in the second argument
and if that is so you know something
that looks like this okay imagine that
um you know the the
estimator is one dimensional
and the distribution is one dimensional
it's not right but let's just imagine
then you know you want if you look at
this with respect to the distribution it
is concave
actually
you can see it's concave here right it's
an inverted ball but if you look at it
with the speed of the estimator it's
complex right
so if it's something like this
then the min max is equal to the maximum
right so this is a very very classical
theorem
and
this optimal the resulting optimal
solution is called
again a classical
nash equilibrium
and there are actually many efficient
algorithms to obtain the nash
equilibrium including just very simple
gradient the center set okay so
um i
just
iteratively update the hat and
iteratively update theta star just along
the gradients respective gradients and
that would converge to the number
equilibrium provided r is convex concave
okay so everything would be wonderful if
r is convex concave but the unfortunate
reality is that even for very simple
things like squared laws and linear
regression and stuff like that
the statistical game is not convex
concave it'll look a lot more like this
rather than a very nice figure uh in the
previous slide so in particular you
definitely the min max theorem is not
going to hold okay so min
theta hat max theta star is not going to
be equal to the max theta star and then
theta hat that's definitely one thing
but the other more critical problem is
that
the um this is a very very difficult
optimization problem to solve
especially considering
even setting aside the non-complexity
considering the domain of theta which is
the set of all possible estimators
okay it's clearly a very very large set
so what do people typically do when
faced with such non convex concave games
let's not worry too much about the
domain
really intractably large domain for now
let's just imagine in fact even just a
typical finite um zero sum games if it
is non i guess if it's finite um
it's relatively easy but
for simple zero sum games
how do i solve uh such a zero sum game
when r is not convex concave what we
typically do is we lift the problem
um or what you know uh
so what is done is you linearize the
game so instead of the actions being the
set of possible estimators sorry instead
of possible estimators like here right
and the set of possible models like here
you have distributions over estimators
and distributions or
parameters and then what you actually
your objective is essentially the the
which is basically the
loss that for instance the learner would
suffer would essentially be just the
expected uh risk with respect to these
distributions okay so this is basically
the reason i call it a linearized game
is that this guy is actually linear in
with respect to these distributions
right
um so for instance imagine this is
discrete right and um its domain is
imagine that there are only k estimators
so then this would just be um the k
simplex right and you can see that this
would just be a summation of uh um um
[Music]
it would just be a linear function of
those multinomial parameters right
so that's the linearized game and now
because this is bilinear linear in both
the actions of the learner and the
actions of the
um
of nature
um it's
bi-linear and hence convex concave right
so the minimax theorem holds
and you
there does exist a nash equilibrium of
this linear scheme and so we call the
nash equilibrium of this linearized game
as the mixed nash equilibrium of the
original game okay the original game i
just mean this guy
oh okay so
so far so good right so maybe if i can
just
lift the problem
um then i'm in the convex concave space
then uh maybe i can just degrade into
some descent and you know solve the
statistical gain
but not so fast right this is maybe
relatively fine but this guy is a
distribution
set of all possible distributions over
all possible estimators
this is impossibly large if you think
about the typical algorithms to solve
games
they are not really designed for such
large complex
uh games and of course we are also
you know
many of the results are also
breakdown when even in this linearized
setting when this r
um um is not convex and the domains are
infinite
so what do we do
right um so
recently what uh an approach that has
really uh it's kind of an old approach
but it's really got uh quite a bit of uh
attractive quite a bit of interest in
recent years is to solve such zero sum
games
by a reduction to online learning
okay so um again the zero-sum game think
of it as just a one-shot game right the
learner picks an estimator nature picks
a theta star and then you suffer a loss
right it's just a one-shot game but
let's drag this out
to over multiple rounds
and the learner then uh in each round
um
they so this is of course a general
uh online earning setup so let's
actually talk about the general online
learning setup in case it's
not familiar so again this is general
online learning where a learner would
pick an action so again this is i'm
realizing a little bit of an unfortunate
notation but let's stick with it the
learner picks
an action and the adversary chooses the
loss function itself
okay and the learner would then suffer
the loss function um applied it to the
specific action that the learner chose
okay and this keeps happening over
multiple rounds and the overall loss the
learner suffers over t rounds is
basically just the sum of the losses
that suffer in each round
right um but because the adversary gets
to play after the learner they can
always choose an ft that is maximally
harmful to theta t right so this becomes
like a trivial problem so to make this
interesting we the goal
is to actually
minimize the regret with respect to a
single action that is chosen in
hindsight okay so here these are all the
losses that i would suffer in t rounds
and then my goal is to pick um
the best action in hindsight and the
regret is the overall loss you would
suffer compared to this um the loss of
the best action picked in hindsight
and the goal in online learning is to
really do well with respect to this so
so that the overall regret is sub linear
in t
which means that the average regret per
round is uh smaller of one
right um
so you suffer less than constant regret
per round right so that's what you want
vanishingly small regret as t goes to
infinity
now this has again you know it's a very
very important framework and there's
been a lot a lot of work on algorithms
to achieve regret that is sub linear in
t even when these loss functions
are
not convex okay there's there was in
fact a recent work that won the best
student paper award that showed that
even when these functions are non-convex
um there exists
simple algorithms like follow the
perturb leader which you can think of as
something like regularized erm if you
will um
so um um i'll i'll come to that but um
the very simple algorithms achieve
sublinear okay so that's basically just
a quick
um uh detour into just generic online
learning so why is this helpful to solve
a statistical gain
so again
the statistical game is just a single
short zero-sum game right learner picks
theta hand
nature takes of star you suffer a loss
so
one way um that i can actually figure
out what is the nash equilibrium fuel
is or mixed nash equilibrium is to have
the learner and nature play multiple
rounds
okay so over t rounds
the learner picks
um estimators theta hat t
okay and um or let's call it
s and um but actually we're going to
play the linearized game so the learner
is going to pick a distribution
over the estimators okay so let's call
that b beta hat s uh in the s s round
and um the um nature is going to be a
distribution over possible parameters
okay let's call this the distribution of
pix in the s round um and
the
each player would be trying to
um so it's it's like online learning
right so each player would try to
minimize their regret um with respect to
the other players actions so imagine
that both of them play sublinear
regret algorithms or
let's imagine that the specific regret
of their specific algorithms is epsilon
l for the learner and epsilon n for
nature
okay so both of them are essentially
playing
the sequential game
and imagine that this is the rigor they
each of these guys are going to suffer
after t rounds
now let me construct this randomized
estimator that's
basically just
this mixture model over these
distributions
so each round itself i'm playing a
randomized estimator and i'm essentially
going to take um a uniform distribution
over mixture or over all of these
various distributions so this is in turn
a randomized estimator or if you want to
think about it it's a distribution
overall possible estimators
um and
let's construct with a certain nature
again this mixture model which is again
just um just
a uniform mixture or all the actions
that nature took over the t rounds
then what you can show again this is
just a few lines of proof that um it's a
very simple statement that essentially
this theta had this randomized estimator
and this mixture are actually an
approximate mixed nash equilibrium of
the statistical gain
okay and the approximation factor is
precisely the sum of the regress
okay so in other words if i have a
vanishingly small regret
uh um
if the learner and nature play
online learning strategies that are
vanishingly small regret they
essentially get a very very good
mixed nash equilibrium of the original
game
right
now so far so good but if you again
think about all these online learning
algorithms
how is learner going to actually
use
all of those um approaches online
learning approaches when most of either
the analysis in fact the algorithms
themselves
the computational complexity
really
scales with the size of the domain
and even the statistical complexity
typically sales with the size of the
domain and so this is infeasible
when the learner's domain is
exceedingly large right you're looking
at distributions over all possible
estimators
so how do we then choose sublinear
regret strategies for learner and nature
that are simple
um it seems impossible right
but it turns out
that there is a very very simple
sublinear regret strategy that is in
some sense cheating
okay you just make
um the learner
um
act after nature has chosen um its
action for that round remember that here
um you are still free
to
um decide any sub-linear regret
algorithms
um and this theorem holds right
um and so what i'm saying here is that
um
the estimator is actually going to pick
the best possible estimator for that
round t
after nature has picked a distribution
over um um statistical models at that
round t
okay so this is called best response
this is typically not going to be
available in general online learning
setups right
um but
i can do this right this is definitely a
sublinear
uh regret strategy right you would
suffer a regret of zero
um uh actually it will you will
suffer negative regret because you are
optimizing your strategy for the teeth
round exactly to the um
um
uh the strategy that nature played
around t
now if i just think about this again in
the context of the statistical game
this is actually a reasonably
well-defined well-studied
problem in fact this is the base
estimation problem where i have a
distribution over models given by this p
theta star key
and then my goal is to find the theta
hat that minimizes the risk and this is
basically this expression here is the
base risk
um with respect to this prior so um um
all i need to do then is to compute the
base estimator theta hat
with respect to theta t with respect to
this distribution
now don't get me wrong this is a
computationally difficult problem
but there are this is a very very well
studied problem in statistics and
machine learning uh where given various
priors we have various strategies to
compute the base estimator okay so this
is basically a well-defined
strategy right
now what about nature
nature
what it plays is follow the perturb
leader now follow the perturb leader in
the context of nature is a little bit
more tractable because nature is still
working with the finite dimensional
space right again i'm going to assume
that the set of model parameters are
finite dimensional
and of course i'm dealing with
distributions
over
this finite dimensional space so
follow the perturb leader actually
outputs a distribution so what it does
is that you have some noise variables
that are chosen from some distribution
so in in our context we use the
exponential noise with some noise
parameter eta
now once you pick this noise um then
what you do is that you just sum up the
losses
uh or risks i should say
that any candidate theta would suffer
given
all of the estimators of the learner
picked in the first t minus
one rounds okay so this is the nature's
action in the teeth round
okay so in the teeth round
nature looks at all the actions that the
learner has picked in the first t-minus
one rounds right
and it looks at the total loss total
risk i'm sorry that any candidate theta
would suffer but then you also add this
noise term
oops also add this noise term and then
nature would try to optimize
for theta that
maximizes this so this is follow the
perturbed leader
because if i didn't have this noise term
this just this optimization with just
the first term is called follow the
leader the leader because i'm just
looking at um
the data that would um
minimize or in this case maximize the
risk the learner would um
suffer
summed up over the first team as well
knows okay
so um this is a very simple optimization
problem right this is just a finite
dimensional optimization problem
maximization problem
with respect to theta right uh if i fix
sigma
again sigma is just some noise variables
uh and by
varying sigma i essentially get um a
distribution because sigma is random
this in turn is random so i actually get
a distribution over parameters but once
i fix sigma this is a finite dimensional
maximization problem
now again this is
uh computationally difficult in general
but in modern ml we are not faced with
non-convex optimization right it's par
for the course uh again there are
various strategies to to try to solve
non-conflict's optimization problems
this is again a nice well-defined
problem
so what we are seeing is that both for
the learner which is just base estimator
and nature which is just a finite
dimensional maximization problem we have
well-defined strategies that they can
play and once each of them are playing
these well-defined strategies just
computing the average of their t
strategies in the t rounds you're going
to get an approximate
mixed nash equilibrium
which is pretty exciting right
so just to
formalize
basically the computational problems
that we need to solve we
cast casted in terms of access to
oracles okay so i assume that i have
access to a bayes estimation oracle
which again base estimation tries to
solve this problem okay we're given a
distribution p
um and the base risk it tries to
minimize the or its goal is to minimize
the base risk
and my um what i'm going to assume is
that i have access to an approximate
base estimator oracle that
solves it up to an adjective
approximation
alpha um and similarly i'm going to
assume that have access to a
maximization oracle again this is a
finite dimensional maximization problem
and what is the maximization problem
it's precisely the maximization problem
that arises in ftpl right
um again you think of this as some
uh
typically non-convex
optimization problem in theta and i want
to at least solve this up to some
additive error data
now given these two things um um then i
can actually um
what we really want is then for the
specific statistical game
um to say that playing these two
specific strategies of tpl and best
response that i get
an approximate mixed natural equilibrium
for the statistical gain but i need to
make um
some regularity assumptions again these
are very very standard triglarity
assumptions uh to prevent pathologies so
um
the i'm essentially going to assume that
my parameter domain is compact
essentially it's l infinity diameter is
founded let's say
um it could scale with uh n and so on um
and we
our results
actually depend on this d but it's
easiest to just think of this as bounded
um and of course there is function in
slip sheets in my model parameters so
that's also pretty standard
and um i'm essentially um going to
choose the noise parameter in ftpl
remember that in follow the perturb
leader um i'm picking the um
i'm adding in perturbing um the
follow the leader objective with that
linear noise uh with the exponential uh
noise and these are the parameters
essentially one over root t
um
so d is the dimensionality
of
the problem
and
l is the slipshod's constant and p is
the number of rounds
then we have this
theorem again it's a natural theorem
given the earlier proposition but with a
little bit of
subtleties that the regularity
assumptions take care of um if the
learner plays best response in each of t
rounds the learner plays best response
to
nature's follow the perturb leader
strategy and given access to the earlier
oracles and assuming that earlier
regularity assumptions hold
then the randomized estimator
and the mixture distribution for nature
this this tuple
is actually an epsilon approximate mixed
nash equilibrium of the statistical
thing
where what is approximation factor it's
definitely alpha plus beta of the
oracles but also it scales as one over
root t
okay so this term decays
um
with t
right as one over root t
so the more rounds you play this
essentially is going to decay to zero
so that the overall error
um that you're going to deal with
is basically alpha plus beta the error
of the articles
okay so let's take a step back and see
the
um
very very interesting consequence right
by playing these rounds right i'm
learning something about the game and
what am i learning i'm actually learning
a learning algorithm itself because this
guy is actually a learning algorithm
okay i want to emphasize that this guy
given a data set will output
a parameter right so i'm actually
learning a learning algorithm
okay
um and um this is basically um
a distribution over very difficult
um problems
all right so this is basically remember
this is an approximate missed
equilibrium so this is
nature's
um
strategy for to force this randomized
estimator to suffer the worst loss
um so sometimes it's called the least
favorable prior
okay so that's basically um our result
and i i'll talk about the consequences
of uh all of this
but
just to
you know
to talk about one caveat to this is that
i'm providing a randomized estimator
it's not a deterministic estimator right
so if i'm thinking about i don't know
solving linear regression using ordinary
least squares or with regression
um
this is these are deterministic
estimators almost any estimator that we
usually work with so not always right um
are typically deterministic estimators
right whereas what i am uh what this
theorem provides is a randomized
estimator right
so
what if i want a deterministic estimator
so again this is pretty standard
thing that you do in online learning
context where if this risk is convex in
the first argument not necessarily
concave in theory star but at least if
it's convex in
the first argument then all you need to
do is just take the mean with respect to
essentially this distribution over
estimators and that is just a single
estimator right deterministic estimator
and that
would again have the same guarantees as
the randomized estimator
because in that case what you can show
is that you actually have
um you you actually have a minimax
estimator um so you have a nash
equilibrium rather than a mixed nash
equilibrium
um and
you can then say okay you know that
sounds great but in general this risk is
not going to be convex and theta hat
whatever is long convex and theta hat
which it you know even for simple things
like squared losses it's not going to be
convex and theta hat
unfortunately um
uh even given access to the randomized
estimator um coming up with the
deterministic estimator is going to be
np-hard
okay again this follows from
um various standard results
so
that's one aspect of this which is that
for com general setups i'm not going to
give you
um
uh um a nash equilibrium i'm only going
to give you a mixed smash a little bit
more stated another way i'm not going to
give you a deterministic minimax
estimator i'm going to give you a
randomized minimax estimator okay so
that's one thing so which you can think
of as a negative thing or maybe
those of you working in randomized
algorithms is like that's not a big deal
but here is a plus big plus i would say
so the true minimax risk
is this right this is the let's say the
value of the statistical gain
then what i'll do them outputs remember
is basically um
an approximate
um
mixed nash equilibrium which the way we
stated it is basically just a negative
approximation factor so one way to think
about this is that i essentially get a
randomized minimax estimator whose worst
case risk is one plus smaller of one r
star
okay or to think of it as r star plus
something that decays to zero right
this is in contrast to most analyses of
minimax estimators which are sometimes
even called rate optimal estimators
where i the worst case risk is typically
some constant times r star
okay now this constant doesn't depend on
n and other problem specific parameters
right important problem
size parameters but um
it is still it could be a big constant
right and um you can see that this is a
much more preferable state of affairs
competitors
but that's basically something
i wanted to emphasize
now
that said right
it's not all good news because
ultimately we still need to solve
these uh uh oracle problems right we
essentially what we have done is reduced
minimax estimation to solving two
well-defined problems bayes estimation
and um
finite dimensional maximization but in
general these are hard right um so the
question then we were asking is that
could we impose some additional
structure on the problem so that these
oracles become
relatively easy
so one very natural notion that standard
is invariance with respect to group
transformations
so again this is standard uh so if i
basically have um the
model parameter theta then i definitely
want um
the
for any um group element g uh when
acting on theta that should also lie in
script theta and again x
um is drawn from p theta then g x is
drawn from p of g data and then finally
the loss
uh applied to two transformed um inputs
is basically the same as the original
loss
okay so
if all these holes then i would say that
the statistical game is invariant let's
say the set of group transformations g
and then i can also talk about in
variance of the learning algorithm or
estimator theta hat to group
transformations if this holds right
where um i try i transform each and
every one of my samples and then the um
apply the learning algorithm it's as if
i applied the learning algorithm on the
untransformed samples and then transform
the mobile parameter okay
then this is standard uh in such case i
would say that the hand is
um so what we can show then is that you
can
take this original statistical game and
reduce it to a reduced gain where
i can just restrict myself instead of
all possible estimators to um estimate
as the invariant and instead of all
possible parameters i can restrict
myself to the quotient space
okay
which i can think of as equivalent
classes equivalence classes with respect
to the group transformation
which could be much much smaller
and you can go from one to the other
very very easily okay so again that's
pretty standard so let's look at the
consequence of this for various problems
okay so the first problem i'm going to
look at is a very very simple problem
where i have a gaussian distribution and
theta star i my just
identity covariance and i'm going to
give you a single sample x drawn from
this gaussian distribution
and this um true theta star is going to
be bounded okay so let's say it's l2
norm is bounded by b
so given this i this is my statistical
gain right
minimize over all possible estimators
and uh maximize over all possible model
parameters subject to them being bounded
basically the l2
or squared loss um between theta hat and
their start
okay so this is um
seems very simple but again it is a very
very fundamental problem for
consequences even for general
non-parametric regression you can
actually release a whole bunch of
statistical problems to this finite
gaussian sequence model um so because of
that reason it's a very very well
studied problem okay but it's also very
amenable for us to
reason about
but the thing is exact minimax
estimators are actually not known
if this
bound is large enough
um so in particular if this bond is
larger than 1.16 square root d
then we nobody knows uh until our work
um what is the optimal minimax estimator
okay so again the mle is just x right
the mle of
this problem is just x but that is not
clearly non-minimax optimal there are
vase
estimators like jane stein estimator and
so on
that essentially shrink the
mle towards the origin
that have better performance but the
question is what is the minimax optimal
estimator and this was unknown
now it turns out that this is actually
has invariance with respect to the group
of orthonormal matrices
and the group action is just matrix
multiplication
now with this if i look at the quotient
space
it's basically it takes this d
dimensional um
essentially uh scale unit ball and
brings takes
the quotient space brings it down to
just one dimensional
interval from zero to b
okay so all i need to work with are is
this one dimensional um parameter b
and then solve this reduced statistic
again so this is a much more reasonable
problem but i might still need to
solve for the base estimator right which
could be hard so the one-dimensional
optimization i can just grid it and just
solve it easily right the maximization
oracle is kind of trivial now
uh whatever error i want right uh if i
want to beta error just grade it up to
one over beta and then i would be done
um
especially on
under the regularity assumption of [ __ ]
sets and so on but what about the base
estimation outcome the thing is you can
derive the base estimation oracle in
this context in close form
again i won't go in over the exact
expression um but it's
actually available to you in closed form
okay so in this case both the oracles i
have very very efficient implementations
so i can actually algorithmically
compute the minimax estimator and that's
basically what we did
we looked at various dimensions we
varied the bound
to go even beyond 1.16 where again the
minimax estimator is just not known
and the last two are really
our um estimators so
um so far i've just talked about the
average estimator so that's the second
last line
and
in bold is basically just the risk that
our estimator suffers
and the numbers and brackets the duality
gap but let's not worry about that for
interest of time
um so what you can see is that we do
much much better than definitely the mle
better than james stein estimator um you
can think of projecting the mle onto the
scaled unit ball uh that performs much
worse than james stein as is well known
but what
we
are getting is something that's much
much better than any of the classical
estimators okay and again i want to
emphasize that
minimax estimators are just unknown in
this regime and the algorithmically
derived
right
[Music]
um uh approximate minimax estimators
and and just to give you a sense um that
um
uh for the case where d equal to one
um donohold
a few decades ago had derived the
minimax estimator um and he
obtained these lower bounds um and what
you can see actually he derived lower
bounce i'm sorry not the minimax
estimator
and what you see is that the worst case
risk
is very very close to the lower bond
again the lower bound is not exactly the
minimax risk right it's a lower bond and
you can see that we are very very close
to that lower bond
and i want to emphasize that we are
um
probably mini max approximately minimax
right
so another so that was the finite
gaussian sequence model again it has
implications for non-parametric
regression and so on but let's just look
at another simple problem which is a
little bit more non-trivial which is
linear regression
so this is again just the standard setup
where um i have let's say with random
design so my features are just n0i
standard normal
and y i the response is a linear
function of the features and data style
is a model parameter
and these noise variables are also m01
and i'm going to assume that the model
parameters are again bounded okay
so you get this statistical gain okay
this is just the squared loss this is
just a minimax
linear regression estimator
you again have invariance with respect
to orthonormal matrices so again the
statistical game is equivalent to this
reduced statistical game where instead
of working with the scale the unit ball
i can just work with d-dimensional and
d-dimensional space i can just work with
this one-dimensional interval and so
just as we did earlier the maximization
article is just a simple
1d optimization which i can solve up to
any approximation error that i want but
what about the basal
estimation
estimation oracle it turns out that even
in this context
i can actually derive the base estimator
in closed form
um and this is a little bit more
involved involving essentially the
cumulative function of the bishop
bingham distribution um again i won't
get into the details but it's just
if i say that it's available to us in
close form
so what i can again do is
obtain the um i'll get this is provably
minimax
minimax estimator and then again
test it out for different samples
different
problem parameters and we do much much
better than ols or ridge regression
again the the parameters for ridge
regression were chosen to be the best
but even that is not going to help you
right
we do much much better than either of
those um
so just one last application which is
entropy estimation
so uh or a discrete alphabet so here i'm
given n samples
from a discrete distribution
um
so uh essentially x i
is um
so so sorry it should be belongs to one
through d right it's x i
is drawn from a finite space and i
essentially the statistical model is
essentially just a simple multinomial
distribution
right um
and the goal here is not just to derive
the entire multinomial distribution but
just the entropy its entropy okay
now the domain of nature um is basically
the d dimensional simplex
um
so
this would be the statistical game okay
that i would be interested in
um again it has some invariances but
it's a little bit more involved
involving permutations which i won't
have time to get into and again we can
leverage those and so on right so let me
just skip directly to the results
so um what can i do to estimate the
entropy one thing you could do is
estimate the mle which is essentially
just the empirical um fraction of
samples that fall into each of these
bins right and then given that mle i can
compute its entropy that's what i mean
by plug-in entropy plug-in sorry mle um
and um
then i can um look at this
um
rate optimal minimax estimator of
chintel zhao and
colleagues um that's the second and this
is our algorithmic estimator and what
you can see is that it is either very
close or better
than um
this famous estimator for uh entropy
estimation
okay so that's basically with uh just a
couple of minutes to spare um
uh so that's basically our results um
what we have essentially done is
this kind of
seemingly crazy idea of looking at this
mini-max estimation
as just
a difficult zero-sum statistical game
and just directly try to solve it right
um and again i want to emphasize is that
this is the learning to learn right that
we actually care about or automated
statistician or you know all these
different traces um this is exactly that
um what we
have essentially done is that we show
that efficient
computation of
at least an approximate nash equilibrium
is possible so long as
you can
solve or get access to
these two oracles which is finite
dimensional maximization and base
estimation again there are a lot and lot
of heuristics for each of these
so
you can get
heuristic minimax estimators but the
question is can you get probably minimax
estimators for which you need provable
solutions to these oracles which you can
if you can leverage natural invariances
uh in the statistical game but of course
some open questions are can we think of
other constraints that are not just in
variances so that the oracles are
tractable um but the other thing is that
instead of trying to get a very very
vanishingly small
approximation error what if i just want
rate optimal
meaning that i allow for constant factor
approximations um would that allow for
easy articles um and so these are at
least some of the questions
um so let me just stop here
and see if there are any questions
great uh yeah thanks for you for the
nice talk any questions
maybe i'll ask one um so
yeah i was wondering like in this last
example with the entropy
uh how i it looked like the some other
method was doing slightly better than
yours but i thought yours was sort of
guaranteed to get the best possible risk
right
right so we uh only get uh
approximate minimax optimal uh
optimality so we get an approximation
error
and sometimes at the approximation error
could be larger
sometimes it could be small
that's uh okay and the approximation
comes from things like how many
iterations you run or like
something like if you choose chose your
parameters
exactly right you could make it better
exactly so let if you go to the theorem
um
the approximation error is given here so
all of the things that you mentioned are
exactly done so the first term is the
number of iterations we run typically we
don't run it for too many iterations
um so you this is the first term and
then the second term are the
approximations introduced by the oracles
themselves so maybe you don't solve the
optimization
um
exactly up to some tolerance and and so
on
got it thanks
uh yeah okay one more question here
uh thanks for the great talk um
regarding the first two examples
it seemed like you heavily used the
rotational variance of the gaussian
distribution
so will this work for
non-identity or non-diagonal covariance
that's a very good point in which i
slipped under the rug right but um so
um yeah
i guess if
it's a question of
what would be the invariances that it
would satisfy um again we didn't
stress test that too much but that's
basically what you need to answer this
specific
um
invariance won't hold in that general
case
you're absolutely right
in that case what i would do is maybe
just work with the re-parameterized
problem right um
so let's go to the problem
if i look at i don't know um linear
regression that's
so if i go to
linear regression then um if i could
maybe coop the covariance in the theta
star right
then i so long as i don't know the
spectral norm of the covariance is
bounded then i can push that into this
and
try to recover
essentially the scaled parameter because
that makes sense
so i could do that things like that
but um yeah ultimately it's a question
of if these specific distributional
assumptions don't hold
then what ingredients would be
satisfying
okay uh one more question
um just a quick one um so this this sort
of was
you know sort of an operational
interpretation of um of many max risk
and that you don't actually care about
our star you're just going to get to it
um is there a sense in which or examples
of problems in which you can also with
the same type of framework characterize
our star maybe up to a constant or
something like that
by characterize our star
so i mean like in the entropy estimation
question right you can sort of there are
other results that will tell you like
how our star would scale or
or how the how the sort of minimax
scales in terms of other dimensions in
the problem or other parameters of the
problem but this doesn't care about that
clearly you're just telling me it's it's
an additive approximation to our star
i'm just wondering if
uh there's a sense in which you can you
can understand the sequence itself
exactly so this does it so
the first part which is r star we do get
r star you do get the value of the game
so you can compute the value of the game
right just plug in the theta hat and the
data stars that you compute and then
you get the value of the game so you do
get r star itself
but you what you do not get is how it
depends on various
problem parameters or maybe even uh you
may like some simple expression
um maybe you just want the functional
form of the
the minimax estimator what we really get
is a um
sample based approximation to the least
favorable prior
so what you then have to do is given
that
um
that's
the take away from this
then given that you need to again derive
the functional form of that prior
and then given that you need to derive
the functional form of the corresponding
base estimator um
yeah yeah so we
i haven't talked too much about that but
you could do that in some of these
simple cases
um like the
um there's there's a lot of intuition on
on that for the finite gaussian sequence
model there were various conjectures
on what would be the optimal
uh
least favorable prior um and so we
provide some insight into that but yeah
in the completely general case um
this is purely algorithmic
it's a interesting open question how do
you take
this algorithmic outputs and extract the
functional form
but that's a very very good question you
know
[Music]
okay great any other questions
um all right if not let's thank freddie
again
thanks everybody
so that's it for today uh